a skater of X means Hong Kong
exploration Hong Kong heritage has
become a very important issue I think
it's this sort of growing kind of
resentment among young people what kind
of place we're living in now where do we
come from what our relationship with
China and urbex is a kind of almost like
an offshoot of that why we explore this
these these sites is also kind of
understanding our heritage - I think
this cell doors very beautiful it's
really old-school it's come off its
hinges from decay and deterioration this
is how it actually was looking people
were trapped in this cell like 10 years
ago 15 years ago if there is a guard he
or she will generally be them at the
main gate
she's sleeping so keep it quiet